[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à strasbourg pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo émissions spéciales les
révélations autour des parades à spurs
ont eu un effet détonateur en france et
en europe le commissaire européen pierre
moscovici demande qu'une liste noire des
paradis fiscaux soit établie allez
paradise peppers montre comment des
sociétés comme nike apple whirpool ou
dassault utilisent tous les systèmes
d'optimisation fiscale a pour échapper
aux impôts ou taxes ou à la tva
ce sont des milliards qu'ils sont placés
dans des paradis fiscaux des pays dont
la législation fiscale est réputé être
plus généreuse qu'en france par exemple
évasion fiscale ou optimisation fiscale
la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale s'est
beaucoup de promesses mais peu de
résultats en europe
on en débat avec nos invités eva joly
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne du
groupe des verts et vice président de la
commission des enquêtes sur l'évasion
fiscale vous accusez à les mauvais
élèves de l'union européenne d'empêcher
une réforme contre les paradis fiscaux
un parmi eux selon vous le luxembourg
les pays bas l'irlande et le royaume uni
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
face à vous jean arthuis bonjour vous
êtes député européen de l'alliance des
démocrates et libéraux pour l'europe à
centriste on se rappelle aussi à
l'ancien ministre de l'économie merci
d'être venu enfin philippe juin bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes député européen du groupe ppe
qui recule qui regroupa ici au parlement
européen la droite et une partie du
centre en france vous êtes membre du
parti les républicains qui demandent la
publication de la liste noire des
paradis fiscaux a pour m les pays qui
sont inscrits je cite à la diète
budgétaire européenne vous allez nous en
dire plus mais avant un retour en images
96 médias dans 67 pays ont révélé les
paradise peppers un vaste circuit
planétaire d'optimisation fiscale parmi
ces révélations des entreprises
françaises comme dassault aviation ou
totale ou des grandes fortunes comme
bernard arnault ou philippe starck un
des pratiques contestables mais les gars
là qui font perdre chaque année 20
milliards de dollars à la france le
commissaire européen à la fiscalité aux
affaires économiques pierre moscovici
s'est dit profondément indigné
promis de frapper au portefeuille les
fraudeurs et paradis fiscaux lors d'un
débat ici au parlement européen à
strasbourg onoratini
[Musique]
de la reine d'angleterre en passant par
shakira lewis hamilton ou bernard
arnault des personnalités bien
différentes mais qui ont un point commun
l'optimisation fiscale
les paradise peppers ont révélé
plusieurs moyens d'échapper à l'impôt ou
de le réduire au minimum les
multinationales sont évidemment les
championnes du système ainsi le géant
apple
le groupe américain a déménagé son siège
européen sur l'île de jersey où le taux
d'imposition sur les sociétés émules 110
milliards d'euros de profits non imposée
pour les européens
la pilule est difficile à avaler
beaucoup d'autres sociétés comme
facebook ou world poule et chaptal
impôts via des sociétés écrans ou encore
en exploitant des failles de la
législation
hormis les grandes entreprises les
particuliers aussi savent se faire
conseiller pour échapper à l'impôt très
symbolique
le cadet d'elisabeth ii a suscité
beaucoup d'émoi de l'autre côté de la
manche
via sa société le duché de lancaster la
reine a investi 11 3 millions d'euros
dans des paradis fiscaux
6 millions d'euros ont été transférés
dans un fonds aux îles caïmans qui a
lui-même investi dans une société
d'électroménager
ce montage a généré pour la seule année
2008 trois cents ou mille euros de
bénéfices sur lesquelles la reine noor a
payé que 0,4 pour cent d'impôt
mardi le parlement de strasbourg a
consacré sa séance plénière au dossier
des paradise peppers et comme la
frontière entre optimisation et évasion
fiscale est souvent floue
les dirigeants européens entendent
frapper fort au fond maintenant l'enjeu
est sur la table c'est de gagner la
bataille contre l'évasion fiscale dont
18 mois nos concitoyens vont voter pour
élire un nouveau parlement européen et
si nous faisons pas la preuve de
changement ce sujet fondamentaux
fondamental nous perdrons tous ces
élections au profit des populistes des
cyniques qui en vérité ce sont les
alliés des fraudeurs
parmi les mesures préconisées une liste
noire des paradis fiscaux assorties de
sanctions dissuasives évoqué également
l'obligation pour les banquiers et
cabinet de conseil de déclarer au fisc
que le schéma d'optimisation fiscale de
leurs clients là encore sous peine de
sanctions des mesures maintes fois
réclamé avec un succès mitigé
et pourtant l'évasion fiscale représente
un manque à gagner de 350 milliards
d'euros par an dans le monde
120 milliards pour l'union européenne et
20 milliards pour la france
voilà on l'a vu un pierre moscovici qui
veut la création d'une liste noire des
paradis fiscaux c'est une vieille
demande pourquoi ça n'a pas été fait
avant
qu'est ce qui bloque qui bloque eva joly
ya toujours une très grand réticences
politiques à inscrire des pays sur cette
liste noire
aujourd'hui l' ocde n'a qu'un pays sur
sa liste et ses taux bas go on imagine
l'importance de tobago comparé aux
autres paradis fiscaux donc la création
d'une liste européenne avec des critères
européens qui va au delà de l' ocde est
une des recommandations de la commission
denquête c'est un luxe taxes 1 et 2 et
donc la commission s'exécute
elle l a proposé énormément de textes et
qui était dans nos recommandations
mais ces textes restent bloquées nous en
parlerons donc la liste elle est
attendue pour le 5 décembre
et le problème c'est moins les pays qui
vont être sur cette liste
nous pensons que ça sera peu près 12
cette fois ci que les sanctions qui va
être du bon avec yvon a dû vous donc ce
qui figurait sur une liste certes c'est
déshonorant mais il faut des sanctions
et pour moi il faut dénoncer déjà les
accords fiscaux
il ne faut pas qu'ils puissent
bénéficier de l'aide au développement
des investissements de nos banques
d'investissement et ses fausses bonnes
fonctions c'est pour les sentiments qui
a une liste donc il faut qu'ils les
sanctions qu'ils aillent avec
jean arthuis d'abord je crois qu'il faut
il faut qu'on soit un peu claires nous
sommes dans un monde où l'hypocrisie est
totale on voit bien que les états ont
tous leur petite pratique et ce qui
suscite l'optimisation fiscale
c'est d'abord le taux très élevé des
prélèvements obligatoires
et comme les taux sont très élevés tous
les états s'efforcent d'avoir des
exonérations d exemption des abattements
des réductions des niches fiscales
ça c'était une rente extraordinaire pour
les dire c'est que s'il ya des paradis
fiscaux c'est qu'il ya des enfers
fiscaux aussi oui et que c'est un et que
c'est une rente extraordinaire pour tous
les cabinets d'avocat conseil en
fiscalité
donc soyons un peu réaliste parce que
tous les états de l'union européenne
pratique d'une manière ou d'une autre
des abattements excessif la france par
exemple
qu'est ce qui justifie qu'on exonère la
coupe du monde de football on exonère la
fifa c'est déjà une exception c'est du
tax ruling alors certains sont allés
jusqu'au bout du bout et l'urgence c'est
de saisir l'opinion publique
il ya eu deux occasions mois il ya eu
luc slicks il ya eu ensuite panama
peppers qu'est ce qui s'est passé ici
pas c'est qu'à ce moment là les
ministres des finances de l'union
européenne se sont réunis à vendredi à
bruxelles
ils ont fait un communiqué endurant
voilà on s'est mis d'accord pour engager
la lutte contre l'évitement de l'imposer
c'est beau comme l'antique ça en fait
ils n'ont rien fait et et l'hypocrisie
est totale je pense que l'europe a
intérêt à mettre de l'ordre dans sa
maison et philippe juvin vous aussi vous
êtes intervenu vous voulez cette liste
noire des paradis fiscaux et pour mettre
ceux qui sont inscrits à la diète
budgétaire européenne voit très bien que
ce système très complexe ne peut
fonctionner si que si les règles sont
communes entre les grands états et
que la france l'italie ou l'allemagne
publie une liste dans son coin n'a aucun
effet par définition nous sommes dans un
monde ouvert et vous pour joly rappelé
penser que les pays bas l'irlande
regardez l'enseigné sur la liste de
l'oscd eux c'est un pays sur la liste de
la france ces six chacun a sa petite
liste où par définition
vous avez des trous et main énorme dans
la raquette et donc vous avez toujours
la possibilité quand vous voulez
optimiser fiscalement
vous avez toujours la possibilité de
trouver une solution donc ce qu'il faut
c'est à l'échelle européenne
fixer cette liste elle sera parfaite
c'est à dire que sur les sur les
critères nous ne serons pas tous
d'accord évidemment mais l'important
c'est d'arriver à une première liste
pour lancer la faire et pour qu'on y
revienne plus parce que vous avez raison
de dire que ça fait 20 ans qu'on en
parle mais ça fait 20 ans qu'on n'avance
pas parce que c'est un peu comme à
l'image de beaucoup de débats européens
l'europe public d intention d'agir
et puis quand il faut agir elle n'agit
pas parce qu' elle ne trouve pas cette
volonté politique et jean arthuis à
raison de 5 1 des moteurs
ça doit être au fond le poids de
l'opinion
alors il ya le risque que la morale
l'emportent sur le droit c'est une vraie
question
dans l'organisation des sociétés mais on
est arrivé à un tel point qu'en fait
nous n'avons plus le choix il faut en
tout cas nous le demandons une
publication d'une liste noire assortie
de sanctions claires et que ces
sanctions soient les mêmes appliquée de
la même manière dans tous les états mais
les les règles de fiscalité en europe on
le sait elle se change à l'unanimité
vous dites qu'il ya une liste noire dans
des paradis fiscaux
il ya aussi en europe donc les pays bas
le luxembourg malte ces états là ils
vont être d'accord
ils vont pas l'être mais ça vend bien et
donc il y a un énorme travail qui a été
accompli par la commission et le
parlement suite aux neuf autres
scandales que nous avons eu ces
dernières années
nous savons nous pouvons anticiper que
les usual suspects sont toujours bloqués
donc ce qu'il faut maintenant et je
pense que mes collègues seront d'accord
il faut passer en cours des sessions en
utilisant l'article 216 du traité
du père mais si ces mesures là sont
dérangeants pour la concurrence de
considérer que c'est un problème de
concurrence patrice quelque part fiscale
dans ces cas là on peut passer la marge
brute est simple plus besoin d'une
limite et voilà parce qu'ici on ne fait
pas ça on va encore une fois constaté
que le parlement là il ya un assez grand
unanimité en réalité entre nous il nous
sommes une force
nous souhaitons ce changement le
parlement le veut la commission le veut
quelques pays qui représente un petit
nombre d'habitants bloc parce qu'il sait
leur intérêt leur business model
ces deux volets le produit fiscaux
d'autres pays
la réforme qui nous préparons axis c'est
à dire en règle comme une assiette
commune consolidée pour l'impôt sur les
sociétés elle règlerait le problème
nous mettons des critères pour taxer
aussi les sociétés informatiques
c'est possible et donc c'est pareil
c'est un texte qui va être votée au
parlement avec beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
avec des bots compromis qui sera bloquée
par la suite si nous ne sortons pas de
ce problème de l'année mais tu es et ça
c'est la commission qui philippe juvin
plus les gens voient d'abord qu'il ya
une question d'ordre politique
il faut trouver un poids politique
suffisant pour imposer ce qui paraît
impossible regarder la sphère du secret
bancaire
pendant des années on a dit qu'on n'en
sortira jamais quand on est sorti du
secret bancaire
c'était pas évident vous m'auriez dit il
ya 20 ans le secret bancaire ça sera
fini en europe
eh bien nous n'irions pas cru en nous si
nous y sommes arrivés
donc ce qu'il faut c'est que
politiquement la france l'allemagne le
moteur politique de l'europe
pardon en profitant un peu du départ des
britanniques
j'ose dire ça tombe bien quand même et
bien impose aux autres leur volonté et
on a des solutions politiques ne plus le
traiter comme le dit eva d'une manière
fiscal parce que là pour le coup il
faudrait l'unanimité qu'on n'aura pas eh
bien on trouvera d'autres solutions mais
on peut politiquement donc
le moment est mûr je crois il ne faudra
pas se tromper aussi sur un des vrais
sujets c'est que nous devons aussi avoir
une transparence totale sur tous les
aspects fiscaux c'est pour ça que sur
l'impôt sur les sociétés il faudra
laisser les états fixer librement leurs
taux comme c'est le cas actuellement
mais au moins avoir une base commune de
définition sur laquelle s'appuiera le
taux voté par l'état parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des taux qui
varie et une base qui n'est pas défini
de la même manière donc ce qui manque
réellement dans la sphère c'est la
transparence
jean arthuis ou d'intérêt transparence
et la simplicité et la lisibilité sur
l'hiver vient d'évoquer la le secret
bancaire
lorsque les américains se sont occupés
de la suisse ça a duré une semaine
exactement face à l'europe
les européens ont été incapables de se
mettre d'accord entre eux par rapport à
la suisse sur ces questions le seul
remède c'est l'europe voit bien qu'au
plan national les états n'ont plus de
prérogatives et ce qui se passe c'est
que les contribuables les citoyens
exaspérés par ce par ces scandales met
en cause la mondialisation et à ce
moment là la tentation est très fort de
se replier sur soi sur les frontières
nationales
ce qui donne impasse totale il n'y a que
l'europe qui peut nous en sortir alors
le juridique peut faire avancer
madame v stagaires la commissaire
chargée de la concurrence s'occupe par
exemple de google très bien mais
immédiatement l'état irlandais
protestent et immédiat les google vint
jersey est et ils vont à jersey bon on
voit bien que c'est pas c'est pas alors
c'est vrai qu'il faut la règle de
l'unanimité
mais la seule façon de faire bouger les
chefs d'état ou de gouvernement le chef
d'état gouvernement qui ont la tête dans
le guidon qui va pas plus loin leurs
regards ne va pas plus loin que la
prochaine échéance électorale il a
toujours un qui est à moins de six mois
des élections
c'est l'opinion publique c'est l'opinion
publique qui va permettre de bouger et
les élections de
2010neuf doivent être l'occasion de
poser ses problèmes sur la table on n'a
jamais eu autant besoin d'europe et ceci
suppose que les états aient la sagesse
de réviser leur fiscalité qui est devenu
d'une complexité folle volontaire et
c'est cette complexité comme ils mettent
des taux très élevés c'est toujours très
plaisant de dire à l'opinion but est de
regarder on taxe les riches très bien et
immédiatement on prévoit des exceptions
des exonérations et on offre par des
voies légales des échappatoires
c'est le bal des faux culs c'est
l'hypocrisie totale alors il faut en
sortir
vous parlez de vous parler de jersey on
attendait une perte direction jersey
donc au large des côtes françaises
la petite île anglo normande de jersey
figure en bonne place dans les
révélations départ à la sp passe une
publicité 1 dont les habitants se serait
bien passé on regarde et on réagit juste
après
[Musique]
au large des côtes françaises
la petite île anglo normande de jersey
les paradise peppers démontre que la
société californienne apple épinglé en
irlande pour ne pas payer suffisamment
d'impôts a discrètement choisi cette île
comme nouvelle résidence fiscale
résultats 128 milliards de dollars
serait hors de portée du fisc une
publicité dont les habitants de l'île se
serait bien passé je pense que c'est du
journalisme irresponsable
la raison étant que tout cela était
sensationnalisme il faut accepter qu'il
y a de toute façon une obligation
professionnelle au secret cela donne une
nouvelle réputation et ligne magique on
a un beau soleil aujourd'hui ça va juste
mais à l'image de l'île et repousser les
visiteurs et dissuader les gens de venir
en vacances
oui bien sûr que c'est la déprime lille
a développé une fiscalité très
accommodante
le taux de l'impôt sur les sociétés
s'élève à 0 % le taux maximum de l'impôt
sur le revenu est fixé à 20% des
chiffres qui contribuent à faire de
jersey une place attractive
alors ici révélation des paradise
peppers joue pas on veut garder ce
statut privilégié
je peux certainement comprendre l'aspect
moral quand on sait qu'apple transfert
c'est profilage est richesse et qu'on
veut voir ça comme une mauvaise chose
mais là encore cette activité
parfaitement légale et si le
gouvernement de jersey prend réellement
des mesures pour lutter contre cela et
se rattraper aux yeux du public
c'est certainement une possibilité je
pense qu'en fin de compte
apple va simplement aller ailleurs après
les révélations la réaction du groupe
apple est immédiate
si l'entreprise paye aussi peu d'impôts
en europe c'est pour en payer plus aux
états unis berceau d'apple une sorte de
nationalisme fiscale
un argument plus aura du mal à
convaincre hors d'amérique
[Musique]
voilà a plein qui aurait logés 128
milliards de dollars à jersey en
réaction à ces révélations la firme
américaine a prétendu privilégier le
fisc américain au détriment du reste du
monde vous dit quoi
ce n'est pas vrai près d'un pont de
nulle part
il ya déjà eu des hearing au sénat
américain qui est à l'origine de apple
et de la révélation du fait qu'ils
paient 0.05 en irlande
donc aujourd'hui ils réussissent à ne
payer d'impôts
nulle part on a vu dans paradise paper
que les territoires uk sont impliqués il
n'y a pas que les demandes jersey il ya
aussi tous les territoires
le sort s'est plus de l'optimisation
c'est de l'évasion fiscale c'est quoi la
différence vous savez je vais d'abord
finir en train de vous dire je réponds
après je signerai ça c'est pareil ça
fait des décennies que nous acceptons de
nous faire piller pillé nos produits
fiscaux parce que l'anglais à nous dit
qu'elle n'a pas le contrôle sur ces
territoires ce qui est aussi faux moi je
propose et les verts proposent que nous
faisons des nettoyages de ce système une
des conditionnalités dans les bric sic
si l'angleterre veut l'accès au marché
unique elle doit mettre de l'ordre dans
ces territoires là qui dépend d'elle et
dont elle a pu tirer ce bénéfice pendant
40 ans parce que en fait les flux
financiers de cité ils viennent de là
ils sont tout à fait mélangez donc nous
avons une possibilité historique de
faire le ménage célébre excite cette île
un des ponts du régime britannique est
ensuite quelle est la différence entre
la fraude et optimisation bout alors je
dirais que c'est très rare m'a testé
devant les tribunaux qui est à peu près
tous les états membres ont la notion
d'abus de droit
le fait de faire des montages dont le
seul objectif est de ne pas payer
d'impôt est interdit un peu partout mais
comme c'est très difficile à prouver
c'est
c'est très difficile à prouver ça se
termine toujours par des transactions
dont il ya pas beaucoup de choses près
dans ce match je dirais qu'il ya
beaucoup plus de fraude qu'est-ce qu'on
veut bien admettre et si on dit que
c'est légal c'est donc il faut changer
la loi parce que cette situation là elle
est intolérable
ce que je voudrais rappeler à vos
téléspectateurs que l'impôt c'est aussi
la civilisation c'est notre vivre
ensemble
ce sont les universités c'est la culture
c'est les routes et les hôpitaux et qu'
il doit pas avoir des passagers gratuit
comme aujourd'hui les multinationales
deux choses d'abord nous ce que nous
proposons c'est que dans le cas
d'opérations complexes légal mais
complexe organisés par des sociétés de
conseil qui permettent à des sociétés ou
des particuliers de profiter pleinement
du droit fiscal et il n'y a pas de
malhonnêteté il ne faut profiter de
failles du droit
nous proposons que ces montages
complexes soient transmis aux autorités
de aux autorités fiscales des pays
concernés ce serait une manière cette
année mais chaque jeudi sur les
intermédiaires
ils sont pires que s'il reste pas moi
qui ait un vrai sujet c'est que au fond
l'évasion fiscale arrange tout le monde
comme vous le disiez c'est le bal des
hypocrites pourquoi parce que ça arrange
évidemment ceux qui en bénéficient en a
jugé rejet ça arrange de bénéficiaires
qui va mettre son argent c est ça
arrange aussi d'une certaine manière par
dont l'état à l'origine de l'enfer
fiscal la france l'allemagne l'italie
sont d'une certaine manière satisfait de
ne pas avoir à rendre totalement
transparent leur système fiscal et à ne
pas l'avoir suffisamment transparent
pour qu'il ne puisse pas être comparé
aux autres le sujet là c'est que nos nos
régimes fiscaux sont devenus tellement
complexe illisible par la population
bref quasiment anti démocratique que
on trouve scandaleux qui est des régimes
fiscaux dérogatoires et des endroits qui
sont des des paradis fiscaux
mais en même temps on se dit que c'est
la manière pour nous de pas rendre
transparent et pas pouvoir se comparer
d'une manière transparente aux autres il
ya aussi ce sujet nous avons créé des
enfers fiscaux par jean arthuis ainsi il
ya des paradis fiscaux c'est qu'il ya
des enfers fiscaux
ainsi l'impôt sur les sociétés était
moins élevé en france la france elle
serait plus l'attractive la
mondialisation a totalement changé la
donne
le numérique fait que on vit dans le
village planétaire et donc ses idées que
nous avions dans le monde d'hier sont
devenus sont devenus totalement
inapplicable donc même en termes
d'imposition
on a tendance à vouloir imposer les
entreprises à prélever l'impôt sur la
production mais at on bien conscience
que dans une économie qui se mondialise
en chargeant les coûts de production
nous amenons complice des
délocalisations d'activités et d'emploi
continuer à faire comme nous le faisons
à taxer la production
ces programmes et le chômage fin de la
production et la fin de la production
donc mettons un peu d'ordre dans tout ça
parce que en définitive on dit voilà je
taxe les entreprises les patrons comme
ça je fais comme je n'arrête pas
d'augmenter après mes prélèvements
obligatoires il y en a pour les ménages
et y en a pour les entreprises mais en
fait sont toujours les ménages qui
payent parce que je ne connais pas
d'entreprises qui peuvent se dispenser
de répercuter les impôts qu'elles ont tu
as payé dans le prix qu'elle demande aux
consommateurs
donc j'aimerais bien qu'il ya une
réflexion au plan européen pour qu'on y
mettre bon ordre et que l'on cesse de se
raconter des histoires et de monter des
systèmes qui sont la rente la plus le
plus extraordinaire pour tous et
avocat-conseil quand la cour de justice
européenne est saisie d'affaires le
magistrat était assez démuni il a en
face de lui immédiatement sur des
questions fiscales
une centaine d'avocats qui sont payés
sans doute dix fois plus
eva joly contre qui il faut lutter dans
les états où les cabinets qui pratiquent
l'optimisation ou les bénéficiaires
ce que nous avons vu date
les scandales c'est le rôle des
intermédiaires donc les cabinets
d'avocats et les banques
ils sont vraiment la cheville ouvrière
et dans nos recommandations de taxes 1
et 2 et de pannes a cédé réguler mieux
ces intermédiaires
est ce que nous sommes en train de faire
et c'est le texte auquel référence mes
collègues
c'est un texte en discussion et qui va
les obliger à dire pourquoi ils sont
besoin d'un paradis fiscal même et donc
ça s'étend en route
je pense que la solution et vous avez
raison de dire monsieur arthuis qui a
beaucoup beaucoup d'hypocrisie
donc pour mettre de l'égalité ces lacs 6
ou se laisser cctv comme dans dix ans
ici c'est à dire toutes les entreprises
avec une même définition de ce qui est
taxable est la définition commune de
l'axé c'est ça une définition commune
comme ça nous serons d'accord sur ce
qu'il n'y a pas des niches fiscales et
la proposition de réalité la publicité
la publication des données comptables et
fiscales de de l'activité des
multinationales en général le savoir qui
elles paient comme impôts une réforme
qui a été votée le contenu bacon très
important pays par pays et il est en
carafe et au conseil
même ça ça leur fait qu trotteurs
avaient bloqué encore nos amis les
iscles annuel compris ne veulent même
pas parce qu'une entreprise comme veolia
ils sont 2600 filiales il vous ne
connaissez les chiffres qui pour cent
d'entre eux est donc cette obligation
les obligerait à déclarer pour toutes
les filiales
le chiffre d'affaires le nombre des
salariés les impôts payés par exemple
mais pour vous que vos auditeurs
comprennent qu'il ya quelque chose il ya
un sujet supplémentaires qui apparaît
depuis quelques années avec la nouvelle
économie numérique c'est que nos
manières de réfléchir sur un appareil
productif traditionnel évidemment sont
bouleversés par google ou apple
quand google
développe ses produits
intellectuellement aux états unis les
vents vent à contenu en france d'un
artiste polonais où se passe la valeur
quand la publicité est collectée à la
fois en italie et en grande-bretagne
donc il faut que nous inventions comme
nous avons inventé à une époque la tva
qui était pratique parce que la tva
s'appliquait à des biens matériels
comment fait-on aujourd'hui avec des
biens immatériels avec une économie qui
est en réalité mondialisée il faut qu'on
invente de nouvelles bases d'imposition
de nouveaux impôts une nouvelle manière
de voir l'impôt pour la nouvelle
dernière question vous pensez que ça va
aller vite cette fois je vous disais que
c'était une vieille promesse à 2000 2009
nicolas sarkozy qui disait qu' à
l'évasion fiscale
il y en aura plus le trône en 2010 cette
caisse qui veut qu est ce que va faire
aujourd'hui l'opinion par action si
c'est politiquement nous n'avons pas le
choix je vous souhaite qu'elle continue
il faut régler ce problème et sociales
sont les institutions européennes
la gouvernance européenne est symbolique
et est un simulacre de gouvernance donc
l'urgence c'est d'aller vers une forme
d'intégration politique contre ces
scandales le seul remède c'est l'europe
elle revêt une europe intégrée
politiquement si nous voulons que
démontrer à nos concitoyens que leurs
robes sert à quelque chose là il ya une
formidable occasion il faut pas la
laisser passer
on va laisser passer un air si ce sera
le mot de la fin c'est la fin de repas
bio merci à vous trois d'être venus
débattre sur l'évasion fiscale c'était
passionnant la semaine prochaine vous
retrouvez nos rames a dit à bruxelles
d'ici là bonne suite des programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires et la rtbf
bail
[Musique]